Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radio Francia internacional y de
France 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
las elecciones de Brasil la segunda
vuelta del próximo día 30 entre Lula y
bolsonaro nos acompañan en este estudio
para analizar todas las claves Tomás
hisman de Barros doctor en teoría
política en samspo aquí en París
especialista en Brasil bienvenido Tomás
Muchas gracias lamia Guadalupe
periodista autora del libro Jesús te ama
La ola evangélica bienvenida la mía
muchísimas gracias y Pascal es analista
especialista en latinoamérica
corresponsal del diario de hoy
bienvenido Gracias Brasil segunda vuelta
de las elecciones hoy nuestro asunto en
Primera Plana
el del próximo día 30 entre el
izquierdista Lula y el ultraderechista
bolso por la presidencia de Brasil será
un duelo más ajustado de lo que los
sondeos vaticinaban hace meses o semanas
Lula llegó primero en la primera vuelta
pero bolsonaro tuvo mejor resultado de
lo que vaticinaban las encuestas las
acusaciones cruzadas sobre corrupción y
la gestión de la pandemia marcaron esta
semana el debate entre los dos
candidatos en una campaña feroz por la
disputa del voto religioso y en la que
por momentos se agudiza la guerra sucia
de las fake news repasemos algunas
portadas que nos deja la prensa foya de
Sao Paulo las campañas ajustan el foco
en las redes sociales en esta recta
final la revista istoe apela en esta
pregunta a sus lectores vamos a dar
Carta blanca a la tiranía y afirma que
la elección de bolsonaro agudizaría la
deriva autoritaria del presidente
brasileño y seguiría así los países
seguiría así los pasos de países como
Venezuela o Nicaragua la revista bella
en cambio pone el acento en las dudas
que genera la falta de directrices
económicas claras en un eventual
gobierno de Lula Y cómo esta inquietud
puede aplicar a Lula en la recta final
bueno está este Duelo quizás sea la
primera pregunta más reñido de lo que
pronosticaban los sondeos hace tan solo
unos semanas parece que los últimos
sondeos casi dan un empate técnico un 52
48 todavía favorable a Lula no tomas
creo que sí es verdad que es un duelo
muy reñido muy próximo pero una cosa que
no nosotros Podemos mirar ahora es que
los votos están muy consolidados más de
90% de los de los votantes dicen que no
van a cambiar de voto es verdad hay
siempre la posibilidad de algunos
cambios marginales entre los indecisos
pero la yo creo que las cosas que a
contar más el más importante el elemento
de llave es la distinción porque en la
primera vuelta ya miramos como la
distensión no permitió a Lula de ganar
en la primera vuelta y ahora el
resultado puede cambiar si la extensión
es asimétrica y menos gente que vota por
Lula comparece a las elecciones
Buscar las dos o tres claves que pueden
definir que la balanza se incline del
lado del helado del lado de bolsonaro
cuáles habría que subrayar creo que el
tema económico es muy central porque es
el país de hoy es el país de Brasil es
muy marcado por el hambre también el
tema del miedo que también es un país
ahora donde el miedo es muy importante 7
sobre 10 brasileños tienen miedo de
decir para quién van a votar eso es muy
importante pero esto de acuerdo que
ahora está todo muy cerrado lo que diría
es que no nos dimos cuenta nos los
analistas y la gente la campaña nerula
de la fuerza del bolsonarismo Cuánto
está tiene raíces profundas ahora en la
sociedad brasileña Y eso explica el
resultado muy bueno que tuvo
bolsonaro sea en el nivel Federal como
en las otras elecciones tampoco los
sondeos lo vieron venir ha salido
bolsonaros reforzado de la primera
vuelta de Cara a esta segunda Pascal
efectivamente creo personal es Brasil y
obviamente
llamó al a una forma de orgullo que
puede tener raíces en una cierta
frustración de la población y Y eso
funciona definitivamente funciona además
cuando encierres el debate político en
una visión maniqueísta y en eso estamos
hoy en día quizás con consecuencias
además debemos con el voto
evangélico pero Esa visión maniqueísta
hoy en día realmente corresponde a una
época polarizada dos años después Además
del principio de la pandemia de 19 que
tuvo tantas consecuencias en Brasil me
gustaría hablar del clima en la que se
celebran estas elecciones porque la
noción Parece que la noción de
adversario ha dado paso a la noción de
enemigo político Cómo ven este ambiente
enrarecido de o de cierta violencia
política en el que se celebran estas
elecciones no en el que el adversario
político ha pasado a ser un enemigo a
batir sobre todo este es el resultado de
los senos de personal porque es la
dinámica la lógica que evolucionaron
pone en la política al mismo tiempo yo
creo que hay un cierto error de la
campaña de Lula o de Día de intentar
jugar esta guerra sucia podemos decir
del pánico moral
porque lo que pasa es que en la política
aquel que que gana es lo que pone los
términos de la política ese Luna quiere
disputar los discursos el pánico moral
finalmente por sonaron estará siempre en
su zona de Confort la mía Cómo ves este
ambiente
de los problemas de Lula es que habla
mucho del pasado o sea si sigue
vendiendo lo que él aquellos años
exactamente
había nacido o eran niños en aquel
entonces con lo cual tiene un problema
de futuro o sea el proyecto país de Lula
no es muy claro el proyecto país de
bolsonaro es horroroso pero es muy claro
tiene valores tiene está vendiendo algo
y el tema económico para Lula es muy
complicado porque como es Aliado con un
vicepresidente que viene de la derecha
es muy difícil para él tener un discurso
prometiendo más cosas cuando ha
prometido a esta gente que no le va a
echar una posibilidad que está en el
ambiente y sobre la que se especula
mucho Nos ponemos en el próximo día 30
qué va a pasar si bolsonaro pierde la
presidencia se especula mucho un acto a
lo trampa que tengo una deriva a lo
Trump nos acordamos de aquellas imágenes
evocando lo del Capitolio de aquel día
de enero
Tomás va a depender del margen creo Sí
definitivamente Sí realmente hay
espacios son barrios millones de de
votos que separan ambos candidatos y
obviamente que ganelula pues hay de
todas maneras la legitimidad estará
mecánica diría totalmente instalada
ahora si estamos en un resultado reñido
como puede haber ahí sí estamos con
complicaciones y puede haber Por cierto
y lo vemos con ese nivel de
determinación de polarización en el cual
estamos puede haber disturbios grandes
tuvo resultados mejores que que esperaba
no no hablo de los problemas de fraude
etcétera Pero en la segunda vuelta se se
pasa como como Pascal dice puede puede
vender va una vez más hablar de este
tipo de cosas vamos a analizar votos por
segmentos tanto religioso geográfico
como femenino empecemos por el religioso
que parece consolidarse como la Gran
Batalla de estos comicios bueno ambos
candidatos dicen que Dios les guía un
montón de referencias a Dios por todas
partes parece ya que que la batalla de
Dios está en el centro de esta carrera
electoral la mía si la batalla de Dios
pero es una batalla perdida No de cierta
manera porque el tema es que los
evangélicos ahora han adquiridos en gran
mayoría al presidente bolsonario ha
ganado gracias a esos a ellos en 2018
Tuvo una diferencia de 11 millones de
votos evangélicos y ahora de nuevo Lula
está intentando recuperarse voto pero
demasiado tarde pero la otra cosa que
quería decir es que ya no es más un tema
evangélico ahora estamos en un discurso
nacionalista cristiano que va mucho más
allá del tema evangélico que es mucho
más de extrema derecha un poco como lo
que tenemos en Estados Unidos que reúne
la a los evangélicos también una parte
de los católicos y de manera general es
una reunión entre las agendas neoliberal
de extrema derecha y la agenda religiosa
de la extrema derecha y eso se llama al
bolsonarismo hoy el bolsonarismo es más
fuerte que el mundo evangélico pero
incluso Lula intenta pescar de Ese botón
religioso y por ejemplo esta semana se
ha declarado como no favorable el aborto
[Música]
él no es una novedad o sea Lula es una
persona conservadora que tiene con él
una gente que no lo es tanto pero de
hecho a entrar en eso es perder porque
ahora tendría que ganar por el tema de
la familia para como proteger a familia
uno de los errores del partido de los
trabajadores por ejemplo el haber dejado
la familia como valor de la derecha con
una familia La verdad es solidaridad
entonces podría ser un valor de
izquierda progresista y haber decidido
que eso no importaba yo este resultado
hoy que es muy difícil ganar ahora en
este terreno
diría que todo ese proceso
corresponde hoy en día y digamos desde
10 años a esa búsqueda de una nueva
identidad y cuando la mía habla de
nacionalismo
Cristiano
de eso estamos hablando y lo estamos
viendo en todos los países ya con
autoritarismo se está construyendo una
nueva forma de identidad política
republicana Federal en este caso cuyas
bases son estas imagínense pensamos un
poco en lo que era Brasil en 2014 la
Copa del mundial del fútbol 2016 los
Juegos Olímpicos de Río en el río dentro
de otros es decir hace apenas seis años
Y en seis años estamos ya con ese
diagnóstico preocupante esta imagen
exterior que proyectaba Brasil al mundo
En aquellos años de repente durante
estos cuatro años de bolsonaro parece
todo el mundo concuerda que la imagen
exterior del país se ha degradado este
tema importa en campaña a los brasileños
les importa la imagen exterior que
proyecta su país al mundo un poco pero
creo que tiene mucho en verdad nosotros
hablábamos antes de empezar como que
Brasil mismo en América Latina ese país
que habla portugués que siempre que está
un poco aislado del resto del continente
del resto del mundo se piensa como una
gran Isla entonces creo es verdad si si
utilizamos este tipo de argumentos en
los debates a la gente puede considerar
pero no es algo que es muy importante
Perdón mientras Brasil es la primera
economía de América Latina Brasil tiene
totalmente de razón de todas es un
continente en el continente se autos es
auto suficiente en término de influencia
cuando conocemos la calidad de la
administración de cancillería brasileña
Brasil tiene una visión pero es cierto
se vive como autosuficiente porque
continente en el Continente primera
potencia pero creo que para una parte de
los empresarios Eso sí es importante
porque uno acaba perdiendo mercados
también bueno es la imagen que proyectas
al mundo cuando dices por ejemplo que se
está destruyendo la amazonia que se está
construyendo de hecho ese significa
también que vas a vender menos carne
afuera en fin es muy complicado porque
la imagen de Brasil es un producto
también por eso también fuera
inteligente de la agro negocio la
mayoría de ellos se fueron con con Lula
ahora a pesar de haber votado contra
ellos y hace parte de todo ese monto de
contradicciones que tiene Brasil Porque
la mía tiene toda la razón el Amazonas
pero son más de 8 países que estén
consternados es decir que el diálogo
Debería ser constante constante
Igualmente con Francia la primera
frontera de Francia con un país exterior
es con Brasil no es Alemania o España es
Brasil pero así no es el primer cliente
de Brasil es china Entonces es cierto
que existe una fuerza mecánica de de
proyección internacional pero a la vez
no la sentimos creo
en la vida cotidiana vamos a hacer en
este punto una breve pausa tengo un
montón de temas que me faltan vamos a
hablar del voto femenino del voto
geográfico del bolsonarismo Pero va a
ser a vuelta de pausa hasta ahora
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
la guerra está a las puertas de Europa y
recuerda horas sombrías de la historia
la comunidad se ha organizado para
darles ropa
trans 24 está pendiente de los
acontecimientos en Ucrania
con nuestros equipos En el terreno Y
desde nuestros estudios lo mantenemos al
tanto
siga informado siga al día
liberte egalité
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
hablando de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones de Brasil que enfrentan al
izquierdista Lula con el ultraderechista
presidente Yair bolsonaro lo hacemos con
Tomás hisman de Barros doctor en teoría
política la periodista lamia o alalú y
el analista especialista en
Latinoamérica Pascal Dúo Bueno hay
muchos temas que nos quedan encima de la
mesa antes de irnos a la pausa me
refería al voto geográfico Normalmente
se habla siempre de esa distribución de
Brasil que yo no sé hasta qué punto se
mantiene vigente de esos estados pobres
del nordeste del país prolula pero en
los que bolsonaro ha hecho mucha campaña
últimamente prometiendo ayudas Hasta qué
punto
esos movimientos de bolsonaro pueden
hacer que cambie el tablero político
geográfico en esos estados o no Tomás yo
creo que no va a cambiar el resultado
final Pero puede cambiar a la margen
esto
es básico exactamente entonces algunos
pequeños cambios en este estado llave
pueden generar un resultado diferente en
en las elecciones otro margen el voto
femenino que se habla tanto de que va a
ser prolula pero vemos a la primera dama
recorriendo el país intentando hacer
campaña para atraer ese voto femenino de
ahí la importancia de esos de esos
matices puede cambiar lo suficiente como
para traer un porcentaje importante de
mujeres hacia hacia la campaña de
bolsonaro esta campaña de la primera
dama lame cómo lo ve Yo pienso que tiene
mucho que ver con la dinámica de hecho
si se siente que bolsonaro sigue
subiendo lo que es el caso en las
últimas semanas una parte de las mujeres
sí lo van a votar ahora depende de la
capacidad de Lula a explicar otra vez
más que no es solo un tema moral sino
que sería un tema económico porque la
mujer sola que cuida de hijos son
montones en Brasil Entonces el tema
económico para allá central el tema de
la violencia para guía central y en la
cantidad de armas ha subido de manera
espectacular con con bolsonaros o
temáticas que toca mucho a las mujeres y
vamos al tema moral ya va a perder Lula
una parte de esta población porque el
machismo no al final no es lo más
importante es mucho más lo que toca en
el día a día la vida de la gente Sí me
parece fundamental porque justamente
revela creo falla en la campaña a saber
esa impresión de una forma de
continuismo Y ambos candidatos están en
eso Lula dice Bueno los años mágicos de
los años 2000 con un petróleo un barril
a 150 euros dólares Hoy está 84
y ya con esto vamos a volver y
obviamente en la visión Pues de un
Brasil moderno etcétera hay obviamente
está impresión moral etcétera Pero ya no
estamos en eso debemos inventar algo
nuevo dinamizar porque porque
definitivamente bolsonaro dinamizó
electrizó su voto vamos a ver cómo se
cristaliza esto en los medios de
comunicación y un tema que me
apasionante también Brasil que es el
tema de las fake news que lo tenemos que
tratar lógicamente Empezando por los
medios no sé si vieron el debate esta
semana Y cómo les pareció su hubo un
ganador claro las acusaciones de
corrupción una vez más una vez más como
decía aquel que que pone los términos
del debate que en el debate en la
primera parte del debate Luna hablo de
pandemia hablo de economía
ganó la primera parte del debate al
final cuando bolsonaron empezó a hablar
de la moral de la corrupción etcétera
Lula estaba intentando siempre
defenderse Entonces al final creo que
Luna ganó pero no no mucho eh la mía
muestra también que la campaña de
bolsonaro es más profesional de una
cierta manera o sea tiene más media
trading el por ejemplo Lula no supo
gestionar el tiempo se quedó con le
faltaba el minutos para contestarle a
bolsonaro Y eso se ve mucho en todo el
tema de las redes sociales lo que es
increíble porque 2018 ha ganado
bolsonaro gracias a redes sociales y la
campaña de dudas sigue siendo muy poco
dinámica de este punto de vista cuando
se compara a la Revolucionario
que él tiene un que utiliza el móvil de
los demás gente no debería hacerlo
exactamente
es en Brasil apasionante una de las más
distribuidas en los últimos días fue que
Lula iba a cerrar iglesias pero también
la campaña de Lula ha entrado al barro y
ha llegado a acusar a bolsonario incluso
de canibalismo de cosas como realmente
estrambóticas porque tiene tanta
circulación este tipo de bulos en el
país A quién sigue convenciendo este
tipo de de noticias completamente
estrambóticas pero que circulan con una
Libertad pasmosa en las redes sociales
brasileñas Tomás como explicamos esto Es
verdad que la creatividad de la serie es
increíble sí son muy creativos
al mismo tiempo yo creo que la gente que
comparte este tipo de información muchos
casos no cree en el contenido pero
también hacer parte de un grupo es tener
un enemigo en común Entonces no importa
si es verdad usted no es verdad Pero
todo vale para compartir para estar en
este en este grupo el deseo es más
importante que el contenido la mía Cómo
se explica esto de cómo explicamos al
resto de latinoamérica esto de las
fitness brasileñas el tema es que en
Brasil
nadie más lee los diarios en Brasil o
sea verdad Brasil es un país
extremamente conectado siempre lo fue y
entonces son círculos totalmente
cerrados y donde todos circula y en eso
hay el poder de hecho de las iglesias
como estructuras porque las iglesias
tienen sus medios tienen sus cantores y
todo y hay lo que debería totalmente
está prohibido es prohibido por ley la
la presencia de de gente que va a pedir
voto en la iglesia de manera general no
se respecta la ley electoral en esa
elección bolsonaro está realmente
intentando comprar la elección de todas
las maneras o sea va va a Iglesias
dando más plata de lo que debería dar a
los pobres hay una
en fin es muy impresionante el poder de
la máquina que se puso siempre se pasa
pero de esta vez de una manera increíble
es que son muy burdas es decir es que es
que son inverosímiles Porque una
característica de las fake news en otros
países que tienen que ser verosímiles
pero es que en el caso brasileño
traspasan esa frontera eso es el tema y
es esa percepción de sensacionalismo que
que también lleva un poco y corresponde
un poco a ese espíritu brasileño
Entonces sí lo preocupante es que
circule que esté tomado en en cuenta y
que corresponda a organizaciones de
campaña impactando porque Bueno vamos a
hacer en este punto un zoom de lo que
supone esta elección para toda
latinoamérica y les preguntó una
victoria de Lula consolidaría el avance
del progresismo en América Latina más yo
creo que si en verdad la elección de
Lula sería muy importante para el
progresismo pero yo creo que sería muy
importante para América Latina como un
bloque en general porque mismo Juan
Manuel Santos el Antiguo presidente de
Colombia que declaró su apoyo apoyo a
Lula decía que en América Latina hoy
porque tenemos Brasil México los dos más
grandes países eh No hay un liderazgo en
América Latina para la integración de la
región entonces la victoria de Lula
podría ser muy importante para que
latinoamérica gane una vez más una
importancia geopolítica mundial bueno Y
además no sé si corregir la palabra
porque progresismo tampoco sería porque
Lula sería un personaje de conservador
de izquierdas Y borich sí que vendría a
representar un personaje mucho más
progresista es decir dentro de las
izquierdas también meterlo todo en el
mismo saco la verdad Para mí es igual lo
que pasa en Colombia chile o Brasil
porque hay ha ganado la izquierda
digamos pero contra casi la mitad de la
población que votó a alguien de
ultraderecha también entonces estamos en
situaciones muy en el Sudamérica latina
Pero el único país que tiene la
posibilidad de unificar a estos países
rehacer funcionar al mercosur a una Sur
que hoy no funciona también trabajar
sobre el tema de Venezuela con el resto
del mundo es Brasil Entonces es muy
central para para América Latina y para
el mundo diría para el multilateralismo
también en cualquier caso el
bolsonarismo es una realidad que ha
llegado para quedarse es decir aún
perdiendo me refiero por lo menos hoy en
día corresponde a la época que estamos
viviendo en poca detenciones de crisis
lo vimos con la salud y con
consecuencias económicas pero para
volver justamente a América Latina Yo
creo que el momento que en el cual
estamos y en el cual se inscribe esas
elecciones es obviamente histórico
porque América Latina ha cambiado estos
últimos años definitivamente no tiene
liderazgo sí tenemos que integrar la
diversidad de continente además pero en
esa diversidad se está buscando un
contrato social y no se le encuentra
porque la polarización en cada uno de
los países hablemos de hablamos de
Colombia de chile que fuese en Perú
donde el castillo está bajo problemas
hoy en día de México etcétera esa
polarización hoy en día impide Pues esa
concretización de un nuevo contrato
social y de qué estamos hablando además
cuál sería Y de eso estamos hablando
además con una desaparición de la
integración regional la integración
regional es la primera víctima Orgánica
de la pandemia y sobre la fuerza del
bolsonarismo hay que recordarse que los
tres primeros estados del país el
sudeste O sea la parte más rica más
potente del país que es Río de Janeiro
San Pablo y Minas gerais te van a tener
a un gobernador
bolsonarista y eso es muy pesado y eso
también significa que toda la máquina
electoral que
Federal toda esta gente va a encontrar
un trabajo y va a seguir con Mucho peso
en los próximos años otra clave antes de
que se me olvide Cómo han sido los
mensajes en esta diferencia tan corta de
en esta carrera tan corta ya todo es
definitivo como han sido los mensajes de
apoyos de los terceros candidatos
eliminados en la primera vuelta me
refiero sobre todo a la centrista Simone
tvt o a siro Gómez Cómo han sido sus
apoyos Cómo se han manejado esos
mensajes Entonces 0 los dos declaran
apoyo a Lula si no comiendo participa
activamente la campaña Simón sí pero yo
creo que muchos de los votos de ese
candidato ya estaban con Lula en la
primera vuelta entonces
excepto pero para hablar un poquito de
del nuevo contrato social y al mismo
tiempo de la fuerza del evolucionalismo
Yo creo que el bozonarismo como como lo
que pasa en otros países de América
Latina es un síntoma de una región que
tiene un pasado colonialista de
esclavitud a de dictaduras etcétera y
que nunca pudo discutir
como venir a este pasado Entonces es un
síntoma que algo que vuelve porque no
pudimos como si ocupar de este pasado y
cambiarlo
de articulación extrema derecha al nivel
internacional o sea Eduardo bolsonaro El
hijo del presidente trabaja directamente
con la extrema derecha en Estados Unidos
y todo eso funciona juntos O sea con un
guardia por eso la gente dice mira qué
pasa en Brasil Mira lo que pasa en
Brasil pasa en el resto del mundo y hay
una articulación muy fuerte y no es un
tema religioso es mucho más allá del
tema religioso es algo ahora de hecho
falta una narrativa
del mundo progresista Para proponer algo
de diferente que no se consolida esa
narrativa dentro del mundo progresistas
es decir la figura de Lula también
tapona tapona que esa narrativa pueda
pueda surgir es demasiado eclipsa
demasiado por una parte creo que sí
porque porque de hecho no no surgió la
figura y por otra parte del no es solo
Lula El mundo progresista es fue ciego
por ejemplo no no no ha hablado por
cuando se evangélicos con la parte de
los pobres y no no han entendido también
el resentimiento de una pequeña clase
media que ha perdido mucho en los
añoslula que ha perdido el hecho de ser
los únicos que van a la universidad los
únicos que tomaban al avión esta gente
al final paga impuestos este y por un
servicio por servicios públicos de mala
calidad y que que les ha dado nula nada
Claro entonces este resentimiento del
que sería del Pequeño blanco en Estados
Unidos es el mismo y no es para caso que
es el blanco que más vota a bolsonado
esa fotografía última con la que nos
quedamos de lamia un placer haberles
tenido aquí en este en este en Primera
Plana para analizar lo que será esa
vuelta definitiva del día 30 Seguiremos
aquí muy pendientes de ello en rfi en
France 24 de todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana Muchas gracias
[Música]